what do you think about the idea of text
it
text it so let me give some let me give
some color to it so
we can uh cover how this conversation
came about with text it
um the word text texted succession and
texas are being mentioned more
frequently
and by actual politicians the supreme
court's
dismissal of the texas lawsuit against
four other states regarding presidential
election has the lone stars of
state republican chairman alan was
suggesting a u.s split
earlier in the week texas state
representative kyle biederman
tweeted out that he plans to file
legislation to give texans a vote for
texas to re
reassert its status as an independent
nation the movement for texas to leave
the union has been dubbed
texted thoughts
well am against it period end so i'll
put that out there
uh that being said if you're talking
pure
economics here our borrowing costs would
likely be lower than the nation as a
whole
we have one of the most diverse
economies in the country
dallas itself is the number one
commercial real estate
market in the nation today uh we are the
largest exporting state
in the nation we export more than
california we're the second largest
economy
uh in the country and we have an
infrastructure
uh that is second to none in terms of
the capacity and capability of being
economically
independent as a nation we do texas does
texas does yes if you're asking me on
paper yeah absolutely why won't it make
sense to do like what would be the
negative
like you know the whole brexit you're
looking at brexit if you have a brexit
you know with a citizenship you can go
live in norway you can go live there you
know if you do brexit and you can't do
that so a lot of people that are working
ticket it's going to hurt some
businesses people and
london are going to take it headquarters
is going to move out of london they're
going to have to go elsewhere so
when you actually go deeper into brexit
you kind of see the pros and cons of it
and i know it's 51-49 type of number
that they're talking about 53-47 so
there's an r if any time it's that
number
both sides have a reasonable argument
why they want and they don't want to do
it right
why would be an argument for texas to do
it
you said you said those benefits but why
would be the benefit for them not to do
it why should they want to stay
in the union what's the best okay okay
so why
are companies relocating from california
to texas
they want to be part of the united
states of america
but in a business-friendly state got it
so they don't want to be isolated they
don't want to be penalized
for because you know that great britain
will be there there will be penalties
sure but that is not country companies
are not relocating to texas
in mass because they think texas is
going to secede from the united states
of america
it doesn't happen that way i totally
agree and i'm a patriot by the way
so i like our flag yeah i stand for our
flag
and again my boys go to a military
academy they stand for the flag
texas benefits by being part of the
united states that is attractive to be
in it makes our economy roar
it it it gives us you wouldn't have the
same
dynamic if texas was not part of the
united states
you wouldn't let me plus i can't wait
until we're
until the economy of texas is larger
than that of california so i want to
stick around just to see that
you said something the other day and and
you know something that you even said
great analogy or metaphor what do you
have the two parents right
one parent is super strict the ones
parent is super lenient
something that you know i'm hearing with
different opinions and so
a quote or
a saying that i think uh reverberates is
you know
uh the truth is usually lie somewhere in
the middle right
where if there's two different opinions
the truth typically lies somewhere in
the middle so for me when i hear texas
wants to secede
emotionally i'm thinking that's
treacherous that's ridiculous that's
treason you're going to leave the united
states of america
that's why we fought the civil war
that's freaking ridiculous like you you
know
blasphemous like emotional logical you
know you pointed out something the other
day it's like well you know maybe for
lower taxes and it's like at what point
does it make sense like at what point
would you say i can't deal with this
anymore
tax wise whatever but again i'm going to
just revert back to the truth is
somewhere in the middle so i know you
have an interesting opinion on this but
for me emotionally it's it's so absurd
to even
think about emotionally but logically
it's like well there might be some
benefits
here's how i process this daniel this is
how i process this
i think the best thing that happened to
coffee drinkers
after they were paying five bucks to
starbucks as coffee bean
i think dunkin donuts started becoming a
great thing because their coffee was
what 99 cents a buck 19.
more drunken donuts in new york city
than starbucks there you go yeah that's
right so
so then you saw mcdonald's came out
remember when mcdonald's came out with
the coffee like six years ago five years
ago i said go try to mcdonald's coffee
it's ridiculous
starbucks drinkers are like dude this is
actually good mcdonald's coffee i don't
go to mcdonald's but i go to mcdonald's
for coffee
who won it who won there the consumer
one right the reality is who won
is the consumer right and starbucks had
to get their act together okay
so you work for a company and they say
well our benefits we offer this
well we're not going to offer those
benefits we're not going to give you
401k match and we're not going to give
you health insurance you go figure it
out
i'll go over here and it's okay this
other oh you know what no we are going
to offer 401k we are going to have for
health insurance we are going to offer
okay great
so this is this is a competition that's
why amazon hires people so quickly
they're going to pay them 15 an hour and
give them health insurance on day one
there you go so the point i'm trying to
make to you is
who is america's competition locally if
people in america want to leave where do
they go
i think there needs to be a place for
america want to leave like for example
right now what america has
is say say the two uh
the state uh uh senators georgia goes
left
and kamala is essentially a major
decision maker in america no more ribbon
cutting no more ribbon cutting right
if that happens what do you mean by
ribbon cutting i mean she's got a
she has a sort of position you know she
has a vice presidential position
unless you mean like actual things that
you should see she's one of the most
powerful vps we've had
powerful vps she becomes one of those
powerful people in the world yeah
dude this is not a joke like georgia yes
yes so she
is now you know the second most powerful
deciding
she's the sec she's a top five most
powerful person in america in the world
so it's going to be
biden g yeah joe biden is true to his
word about being a moderate and being at
president
which i don't think it's going to happen
i don't think it's going to happen i
don't think it's going to happen
so here's here's how i process it the
only way i process it
is okay uh oracle's moving to texas
great better than where they are right
now elon musk moved to uh
to uh uh austin great you know
joe rogan moved to austin hill packard
moving here
goldman sachs is moving their trading
side to miami
you got the uh the not carl icahn the
other billionaire
yeah carl icahn also florida singer yes
that peter
paul singer paul singer moved over there
as well okay great
so so that's moving from a state you're
not happy
to another state i'm all about but now
where do i go if i'm not happy with the
country when your federal
income taxes are going up now federal
income tax where now you're paying 60
the federal income tax goes to 60 now
where you're going so federal income tax
goes to 60
top line revenue you're making a million
bucks you pay 60 percent of that you
keep 500 of it your tax dollars are
going to bail out all the blue states
that
100 so now watch this so you make a
million something
that's so much money you're not making a
million you're really going to end up
making 400 and then if you're living in
a state that's
charging another 10 percent so then you
so you're gonna end up being stuck with
three hundred thousand dollar income
give or take say three
the whole us economy will slow down as
well so your property taxes are going up
no matter where you live
so so if that happens where do i go do i
go to new zealand
do i go to uh new zealand is a rock star
i know they are that's where we go
do i go to new zealand do i go to do i
go to panama
do i go to you know canada i mean
there's there's always canada well
you don't mind the cold if you do i go
to canada do i where do i go
so i i think the the way i'm processing
it
i'm processing it as i think it would be
actually
a good thing for the american voters
if texas became a country because now
you have and texas is a big land
plenty of room plenty of room to expand
it's not a small place
you got a lot of if you drive in texas
you can drive for six hours and you
don't see nothing
you you can't drive you're still in the
state of town and you're still in the
state of texas so meaning there's plenty
of room for expansion there's plenty of
room for all these
more questions yeah yeah i've got a big
hole to poke and what you're going to do
here we go go for it all right so number
one if you're like i'm a texan now no
more america okay
number one first question that comes to
mind what happens to electoral college
because the
republicans cannot win the uh
yes the they cannot win without texas of
course i mean there's
how many okay i agree all right so
republicans will never win a
presidential election ever again
i agree okay what happens to people who
are living in texas who are like dude i
want to live in america
i mean i don't i get it you have the
choice then cool i'm an american so what
happens to everybody in
texas are you no longer american you are
no longer american i'm just texan
that's it i don't know i'm not a member
i'm not a citizen of the united states
i'm not american i'm just straight up
texan like how far do we go
like what happens with elections what
happens with electoral college what
happens with i'm american
like uh-huh and what happens to all of
those federal dollars that the state of
texas gets to handle its social programs
and what are the what are the carrying
costs and the overhead mr businessman of
running a country i think
i think we're forgetting something here
here's what we're forgetting
i think we're forgetting that the
innovators and the job creators
sometimes just want to be left alone and
the innovators and job creators
want to go to a place where they can
continue to innovate
and job create without being suffocated
you know the idea of suffocation to
someone who wants to be free is is very
very important i mean if you've
i lived in iran you know can you imagine
telling you kids never tell anybody
we're christians okay when you go out
there don't tell people you're
christians just say i don't know what
religion we are you know
don't tell anybody or christians when
you go out there be careful when you do
can you imagine having to give your kids
you already tell your kids don't talk to
strangers don't talk to this don't
imagine all the stuff that you tell your
kids add
40 other things they have to tell your
kids when they go out there somebody
pulls up their mother
the hezbollah posey if this happens if
that happens if this happens okay
so eventually the job creators in iran
you know how people say oh iranians are
so rich oh they're such great business
people it's not that they're great
business people it's the business people
that left iran
that came here the ones that are not
business people some of them decided to
stay there
like i'm getting the hell out of here so
it's not like all iranians are great
business people the business people left
iran and they came and they went to
santa monica
for nine years he taught me all about
running a business there you go they're
great business people right so look at
that
the point i'm trying to make to you is i
think
i think the job creators are not that
worried about it
i think the people that would worry
about it are those
who have the jobs those who have family
in other states
those who love the idea of america but
if the
idea of america say america what is the
idea of america actually go there what
is the idea of america
and if we go in the direction with
georgia all this stuff
then the idea of america is no longer
the idea of america it's still named
america but it's no longer america so
that's the point i'm trying to make you
when i come to america i didn't come to
america you could take the name out and
you can say there's 50 countries in the
world for you to choose from to raise
your kids in
all the names are you don't know it
sweden norway mexico anything it just
tells you the benefits of each state and
what freedoms you have
you don't say i want to go oh it's a
beautiful name i'm going to go to
america you know you say
i'm going to go to this country with
these benefits which one is this i'll
reveal this state oh it's america okay
i'll go to america
that's how families make the decision
they don't just say i love
how great of a name america people come
to america for the idea so if the idea
that the founders came up with is no
longer relevant today
what the hell am i doing living in this
idea that's no longer relevant i'm going
to go to another place
that now is saying these are the ideas
that we have in our country are you
saying that
at the end of the day this all comes
down to taxes
everything no i didn't say taxes taxes
taxes no i didn't i didn't say that
buddy i didn't say that listen
it's not it's not taxes it's not just
taxes i want to be left alone
i want to be able to have an opinion i
want to be able to say something you
totally disagree with me and say you
have no clue what the hell you're
talking i want to have discourse
i want to sit down and be comfortable
knowing that i can have an opinion
in now but part of the united states
can't you do that in florida i can't do
that anywhere for that matter if it's
based on the ideas that america was
started on
yes freedom of speech freedom of
assembly
freedom of you know second amendment
freedom if i have those
ideas then yes so i think i think
look you you know where i'm looking at
moving next it's not like i'm sitting
here telling you i'm gonna be a texan
the rest of my life so i'm not
all i'm saying is i actually think it's
a
very good for americans if texas becomes
its own country
so you would vote for texan to succeed
is that what you're saying
i don't think you heard what i said you
say okay guys guys let's let's play
domino one more time yeah
this is a terrible idea if georgia
doesn't happen and we don't flip all the
way to the other side
okay it's a terrible idea but if georgia
happens
and it's 50 50 you've got kamala biden
two years to add a million and one
social programs that you can't say
nothing about and they're not going to
sit there and say you can't do anything
for me to increase court packing i can
increase it to 9 11
13 15 and own that forever so
i'm going to push back you have to
understand that five
people is not a heavy majority
the house is not insured
the house is not bright blue the house
is a shade the house is purple let me
ask you a question let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question
how often do you notice that
like supreme court you know the supreme
court folks that we have right
trump brought how many of them in three
of them in how many of them voted for
them to go to recount with the other
four
how many of them how many did three none
zero yeah what's the point
republican justices
will vote based on certain values and
principles
their loyalty is to the values and
principles
many times democratic justices will vote
on
their loyalty of their party it's a big
difference
on values and prince i don't know if i'm
making sense on what i'm saying here
so we're saying one of them is a
constitutional
purist yeah that's what i'm saying so a
constitutional empire is going to be
like look i
i appreciate you trump thank you for
putting me in but dude i don't agree
with you
because it goes we just had a real live
test yeah would be so
that's respect to these justices we're
saying all right
sorry buddy of course but that's not the
case with folks
on the other side well they don't have
the majority you're saying but it
doesn't matter historically they're
always going to vote against republicans
supreme court yes so so if you go to
congress
historically historically more right
is open to well you know what i think
it's fair let's talk about this
then left is to say i'm willing to
reason with you
the right is willing to reason more than
the left is willing to reason
the left is not willing to you can sit
there and give an argument they're not
going to sit there and say you know what
pat you're making a good point you know
yeah
you're right you know i'm not going to
pass this bill to raise the capital
gains to 39.6 because it's going to hurt
the economy
nope i'm going to be loyal to my party
it's a difference between loyalty or
party versus loyal to certain values so
i am going to throw something else out
there
there is one overriding factor that
motivates all politicians because
remember the democrats used to be the
party of the people
and that's changed who gets more money
off wall street
the democrats so there is one
overarching
theme that we're leaving out here and
that's lobbyist
and money but here's also what you're
leaving out what the other party you're
leaving out is
who is the source of delivering the
messaging
of that to the american people the media
who controls the media 99 percent
is the left so if the messaging is going
from that direction i can spin the story
like the article came out the other day
saying biden's approval rating of the
people today is above 60 percent by the
hill
how do you measure that today above 60
percent and
so imagine if i'm somebody that doesn't
follow politics
and i'm like you know what i knew i knew
i voted right look people like this guy
already this is great
so the naive voter is just going to be
like okay go good oh okay the night
voter is going to say
oh all right got it so yeah the the
democrats have historically been for
the people who are maybe not the
wealthiest but why are they getting
money from wall street
oh they're getting there because they're
trying to control them so they're not
going to do
there is it's all on messaging
everything is on messaging so
but i i do think that the banks
have a lot i think jamie dimon is i
think jamie dimon is one of the most
powerful people in america i really
really do and i think that the big banks
yes and i think that the big banks would
not
cotton to socialism in america
why did they vote that way though oh
they
uh if if you listen to an an interview
that jamie dimon
made he basically said he basically said
what biden is saying that he's going to
stay down the middle
right so so which happens by the way as
long as the senate doesn't flip
danielle there is say say again it goes
back to the argument of
uh you know you're you're working with
somebody and you're being
more than reasonable with this person
but that person no matter what you do
for them
they don't think you're reasonable no
matter what you do for them
they don't think you're reasonable when
do you win with this person
you never win the video you never win
there's no winning with this person so
meaning
as much as jamie dimon may be the most
powerful person in america
as much as you know biden campaigned on
i'm going to be the president for all
the people not just you know the left
you know i'm going to be this which was
a great message obama gave the same as
well when he gave this dnc speech in
2004 saying
it's the americas of not about the black
and the white
and the algae it's about the lgbtq
community it's about the
farmers it's about those who believe in
the guns it's about you know
and he gave this message like oh my gosh
this is awesome and then he becomes
president never meets with paul ryan and
everything goes politically on one side
so
messaging and execution are two
different things i agree
all right so for me all i'm saying is
i'm not pitch all i'm saying my domino
my domino on why they ought to consider
it as an option
is if georgia goes full left
and that goes that direction i think
people ought to hear the argument of why
that may not be a bad idea to consider
not saying to do it
i think it should be on the table to
discuss what it looks like you like
accountability not just
here's what it is it's not i like
accountability i like competition i
i like competition a lot because
competition is good
for me i need competition okay because
if i don't
if i don't have competition then how am
i innovating how am i getting better how
am i listening if
you don't have competition you actually
don't listen to people you don't listen
to your employees you don't listen to
your partners you don't listen to your
family you don't listen
you you have to have competition
competition is a very healthy thing for
you
you need it right and now we've got one
in five american companies it's the
walking dead so as well
as much as we talk about made in china
2025 and china is going to be bigger
than u.s by 2025
it is it is if we do all these things
yeah as much as we talk about that but
here's the question
how as let's just say china passes
america how many americans are going to
wake up and say that's it
i'm going to china nobody it's not going
to be i'm going to china
yeah but all four of my kids take
mandarin in case we ever have to deal
with them
there's a difference between dealing
with them there's a difference between
dealing with them and moving would you
move your family to china
okay so there's a difference between
communicating and doing that right okay
so all i'm saying is if something
happened to america
where it flipped far far far in one
direction politically
yeah what's your plan b where are you
going i hear wuhan is lovely this time
of year right especially
oh my gosh you just said that again out
loud so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye